hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday February 22nd 2016 what's
going on how how's it going happy Monday
to each and every one of you I was gonna
say to every one of you then I decided
to throw in each so that's why the each
sounded weird different just to let you
know it's another beautiful day out here
in Los Angeles getting ready to go out
to Foxwoods this this weekend right yeah
Friday I'll be in New York City and then
say and Sunday I'm gonna be at Foxwoods
and it's gonna be hopefully gonna be a
good time I'm gonna do a bunch of
stand-up this week so I'm not rusty old
freckles can't be walking in there rusty
and definitely looking forward to
getting back there although I heard it's
[ __ ] freezing
but whatever you know I can visit winter
I'm a big [ __ ] Southern California
softie now I get there my teeth chatter
and when it gets in the 40s it's
actually not true and that's [ __ ] to
where they go yeah blood thins out you
know you blood things out then you go
back you can't handle the cold it's like
no that's not what happens you have
access to information in a beautiful
life that you could be living still
within the parameters of this great
country you know all you people back
there shoveling that wet snow just let
you need you don't have to do it you
know I took my dog out this morning by
Du Bois to do it you know what I had on
I had on a wind break just walking down
the street I could sit out my back porch
in the Sun right now okay and burn
another couple of cancer cars and
freckles into the top of my head while I
had a little bit of cornflakes you know
sitting out there like that douche and
the great nut commercials there's always
some guy right he come out it was like
he was a man's man but a pretty boy you
know like Tom Brady except he couldn't
throw a football that guy right he come
out with
the impossible impossibly white robe
brand-new white robe they even [ __ ]
bleached it right the white is [ __ ] ever
and he you know he's got a little
[ __ ] bullet Grape Nuts always had
some fruit in there cuz he had that kind
of time this guy was so successful he
had to time to cut up fruit into his
[ __ ] Grape Nuts need go out on his
back porch and just chill
mmm Burroughs as a little boy as a
little orange headed [ __ ] freckled
[ __ ] I remember watching that just
going like that guys hey guys living the
life look at him look I got white doubt
Roby's he's got fruit in his [ __ ]
Grape Nuts this guy's crushing it who's
he [ __ ] come on I want to I want to
see the rest of his life lemme see his
life and that was the genius of that
commercial they never showed his bra I
don't think they did maybe she came out
afterwards you know I don't think so but
that's the genius of it it left you
wanting more and you started thinking
about its life and you started thinking
you know what you know if I start eating
great nuts maybe I'll have an impossibly
white robe and I'll come out I'll
actually have pigment my skin you know
nice full head of hair and I'll walk out
on my deck barefoot you know look like I
got all the money in the world I got all
the answers confident as hell and I even
have time to cut up fruit in my cereal I
want that life you know here these years
later to this day you know I'm still
eating great nuts sure I never got the
pigment hey I lost the hair yeah had
some structural damage to my house you
know but I have tried to cut up some
fruit man sorry anyways I yeah so your
blood doesn't thin out it doesn't thin
out you just know what it's like to
experience an 85-degree day and [ __ ]
February and then you go back you just
like what the you know what it's like
it's like you ever see a rich person
have to stand in line
it's the combination of frustration and
confusion it's more confusion than
frustration it's more like wait I don't
wait
I got money like okay here who wants
this who do I give this to so I can go
around this I don't want to be with
these animals these are the people that
make my dreams come true they show up at
my factory all right they put the
[ __ ] the nut and bolt in the widget
that I bought off as somebody else they
came in with the design they didn't have
any money I made him sign a piece of
paper where I own the patent to their
idea I go around all this right rich guy
thoughts and the dead set confusion it's
like well why am i I don't do this
anymore
that's what West Coast people who've
lived on the East Coast then when they
go back east you know when we paratroop
into [ __ ] winter that's that's what
we think like I don't do this anymore
these chapped faced [ __ ] animals back
here I'm gonna [ __ ] do when this
shoveling what snow stretching out your
back you know all excited cuz you got a
new snowblower you know that's your
winner that's for you I go around that
man I don't do that [ __ ] I'm out of my
back porch the bathrobe eat some great
nuts that's how I'm doing it do my
[ __ ] dog is laying on his bed right
now okay it's like from the neck down
it's on the bed and then like its head
is hanging off of the bed onto the
hardwood floor I mean it looks literally
like it got hit by a tranquilizer all
right you know what I did what to do
with the dog today this is why she's so
exhausted after at least 11 hours sleep
last night the [ __ ] thing goes to bed
at like 7:00 at night it's hilarious
like whenever I'm watching the game and
I'm just sitting there she's like over
in the corner just curled up in a ball
sound asleep okay which is why now for
so I can't get her off this clock here
she keeps I don't know how to keep her
up you know because she keeps waking me
up at like 5:30 quarter to 6:00 in the
morning it's driving me nuts
so anyways so now after 11 hours of
sleeping all I did was I took it around
the block that city she looks like she
ran a marathon I don't [ __ ] know I I
don't understand why they're so goddamn
sleepy all the time I've never I mean
I've had dogs my whole life I've never
seen a dog sleep the way this [ __ ]
thing sleeps then it gets up at 5:30 in
the morning like a goddamn drill
sergeant the only thing it's missing is
you know remembered Full Metal Jacket
when the guy came walking in and he was
beating a billy club against the empty
trash can that's basically what she does
to me every morning
except it's way more adorable I'll be
like sound asleep and then I'm woken up
to a cold nose doing that that [ __ ]
psycho way they sniff it does that [ __ ]
it's bed [ __ ] her paint brush chunk
and like that that's how I wake up every
morning I'm one of those people once you
wake me up it's [ __ ] over
alright just just to let you know in
case you ever sleeping next to me you
know keep it quiet
alright let's move on
as I mentioned on the Thursday afternoon
podcast just before Friday I thought I
was going to the the Warriors game I was
going to the Warriors Clippers game and
I was taking the lovely Nia and cuz I
wanted to go see Steph Curry in his
prime you know you got to see them when
they're young before they get the first
major injury or before they just get old
and remind you that you're gonna die
someday you know you don't need to see
that but doing that you know I saw
Michael Jordan back when he had hair I
see him early alright when he was still
skinny and the Pistons were beating the
[ __ ] out of him and he was dropping 60
on the Celtics I saw him then he's
probably I saw him when he would stay
with probably I think was right before
the Jordan threes came out I was
probably the second pair by the way for
the record when the first air Air
Jordans came out I thought they were the
ugliest [ __ ] things I had ever seen
in them in the red and black Bulls
colors I thought they were the ugliest
[ __ ] things
I'd ever seen it by the way Celtics fans
how much more likeable is Pau Gasol now
that he's not on the Lakers I don't know
what it is my hatred of the Lakers
really just made me hate that guy way
more than I needed to anyway so we go
down to the game and I'm down I'm like
ridiculous excited like I'm seeing one
of the great NBA teams of all time and
I'm seeing arguably the greatest shooter
this early in his career you can
actually make that argument this is this
guy is the greatest shooter in NBA
history and in my lifetime I've watched
Andrew Tony Larry legend Reggie Miller
and I'd even throw Kobe Bryant in there
I never saw a guy have two people
hanging on him out by the three-point
line and just with his back to the
[ __ ] hoop and he still somehow gets
it in you know God knows he's not
looking for the open man trying to beat
the double-team why would you do that
anyways so I go there I get on StubHub
right I [ __ ] pay through the nose
you know what I mean [ __ ] pay through
the nose I get a 6-row behind not behind
the bench but almost behind the Warriors
bench but whatever the [ __ ] table
where the announcers are and [ __ ] I'm
like somewhere in there six rows back
and one of the great things is when you
go to an NBA game is like if you're six
rows deep you can like literally hear
them calling for the ball you know if
like if the coach if curse Steve car if
he [ __ ] cursed at the ref like oh
what the [ __ ] and he gets teed up I know
what he said all right that's what I
paid for that's why I went on StubHub
and I said [ __ ] it huh
you want a wheelbarrow full of cash here
you go
I'm not [ __ ] sitting all the way the
Staples Center is the [ __ ] worst you
got to sit down low or else it's like
they got this these brownstone of
corporate boxes three Decker's three
three [ __ ] levels of them all the way
around it's like a moat between the
[ __ ] haves and the have-nots and then
all the real fans they're up by the
[ __ ] air-conditioned ducks
so it's like that's what's the option
eyes either way the [ __ ] up their pay
through the nose so I said [ __ ] I'm
gonna pay through the nose right so and
I'm gonna get there I'm gonna hear I'm
talking I'm gonna watch them one of the
great shooters of all [ __ ] time and I
get that dude and I know during all of
this I'm gonna sound like a grumpy old
man but what the [ __ ] happened to go
into an NBA game dude
they didn't there wasn't one moment of
silence the entire [ __ ] game they
even play music when the [ __ ] games
going on I didn't hear one sneaker
squeak I heard a couple of yo called for
the ball that was it I heard nothing
cuz the entire [ __ ] time the games
going on some [ __ ] do she's playing
everybody clap your hands the hole they
played that [ __ ] 50 [ __ ] times
first of all I walk into the [ __ ]
building right and I'm all excited
where's my seats
I paid through the nose here we go right
it's like when you go on vacation and
use all your [ __ ] miles we're sitting
up in the front of the plane you can't
[ __ ] wait to get on a plane where's
my big comfy [ __ ] seat that I [ __ ]
paid for right that's the level
excitement I had and I go in there now
I'm coming down to the seats and first
of all there's some DJ guy it's always a
[ __ ] DJ you can't even buy a pair of
[ __ ] pants now you walk into a store
there's a [ __ ] some sad-looking DJ
there just sitting there you know with
his bad posture you know some Hathi
j-just [ __ ] play in music I love to
with like curse words in a - like you're
in like a place of business you know
because I'm [ __ ] you - not right
we're playing like biggie and [ __ ] right
so anyways this is [ __ ] DJ and he I
don't know what the [ __ ] he's doing
every five seconds make some noise
people at section 300 if you could hear
me back so I said everybody's like game
hasn't even started but the [ __ ] are we
cheering huh are you getting this hype
for the game you [ __ ] dope we're
about ready to see the Clippers and the
Warriors the words got five losses this
is like watching the 96 Bulls the tear
that they're on I don't need you and
your Richie Cunningham varsity [ __ ]
Clippers jacket out there screaming and
[ __ ] yelling oh it gets worse I might
blow a [ __ ] I have an aneurysm on
this one so I'm walking down going oh my
god how long is this guy gonna be
yelling at us and meanwhile meanwhile by
the way meanwhile you know the Clippers
are out shooting around and the worries
are about ready to take the court I'm
gonna won't get to watch Steph Curry
[ __ ] hit like 18 three-pointers in a
row you know that's what I want to see
that's what I want to hear okay I don't
need back so no I don't need that [ __ ]
right but you know it's a new day it's a
new generation it's their time I'm just
a grumpy old man right so I get down on
my seat that I paid through the [ __ ]
nose for right on the [ __ ] aisle and
that what looks to be it looks like
Steph Curry's mouthguard that he's
constantly [ __ ] chewing on right and
it's like this bracelet and I didn't
know what it was it looked like a
[ __ ] it looked like one of those
things they stick in the bottom of a
men's urinal right a urinal cake except
you get to stick your [ __ ] you could
put it on your wrist so it's taped to
the back of my seat so I immediately
just flip the [ __ ] thing over the
other side of my seat okay
immediately I'm not participating all
right total contrarian kunti [ __ ]
stand-up loner comic I'm not being part
of the group immediately right and I'll
take that I'll take 40% of the blame on
the rest of this [ __ ] wine and [ __ ]
right but the other 60% I'm [ __ ]
right so I [ __ ] flipped that thing
over and the [ __ ] DJ guy with the
richie cunningham varsity clippers
jacket he's down there and he's like
everybody hold up your [ __ ] urinal
cakes and when you hold it up don't
forget to American boys everybody clap
your hands
dude this is all going on right insanity
oh and by the way there's a bunch of
[ __ ] you know like I swear to God
what said was that [ __ ] guy who does
the he sells the nice comfortable
t-shirts but for some reason he shoots
like twelve-year-old girls in like
sexual positions the [ __ ] is the name of
that company it's not amber Connery and
Fitch they were into like [ __ ] wasn't
it like white supremists Kennedy
children I can't you know they it all
blends together it begins with an egg
that's all I know so they got these
[ __ ] like preteens it looks like
comment down you know dressed like
prostitutes and [ __ ] like a be
Hollywood movie right you know aren't
like the ones in Pretty Woman you know
the only exciting part of that was when
he was looking for a hooker and then he
runs into that [ __ ] you know molar
show and [ __ ] champ they're right I
always hate it when he [ __ ] closed it
shut she goes [ __ ] laugh at all those
[ __ ] teeth Jesus Christ I swear to
god that clip right there was why I'd
never dropped acid because if I ever ran
into a woman like that she did that I
swear to God I don't know why what
happened my [ __ ] head would explode
so anyways Jesus criminy got to the
start of the [ __ ] game yet so much
just [ __ ] bugged me so dead doing
dance routines all the [ __ ] so in the
meantime the [ __ ] Warriors take the
court and everybody boos them and
everything and I'm just literally going
like oh my god there he is there he is
here he goes and he starts hitting
[ __ ] threes and the second he does
every [ __ ] jerk-off in the [ __ ]
building right who was it make it so no
it came running down
[ __ ] aisle everybody with their cell
phone cameras out taking [ __ ] video
standing up in front of me here I am
paying through the nose to my seats I
asked them in the six rope I gotta stand
up to watch a shoot around what are you
filming it for the [ __ ] of filming
can't you just [ __ ] just sit there
and watch it I saw Larry Bird do a shoot
around 1986 I still remember it I get
the video right my [ __ ] head he's
[ __ ] dopes all these [ __ ] Yolo
douches come down right with their
[ __ ] phones so I'm just going out
guys yeah you know you're the old guy
now this is this is how the youngsters
do it this is how they [ __ ] do it
right so mercifully people finally end
up sitting down it's the end of the
goddamn shoot around and we're getting
ready to start the game right and I'm
thinking like okay finally this [ __ ]
this this seizure of [ __ ] of tumblers
and hoochies and [ __ ] screaming and
yelling and making noise and bracelets
[ __ ] blinking is gonna end and I can
watch the [ __ ] game right there's no
way this horseshit goes on during the
game there's no [ __ ] way and
evidently it's okay they play music
through the whole [ __ ] thing I'm
watching Steph Curry bringing the ball
up and I'm listening to Drake you used
Okabe all myself
oh do go go go go go everybody clap your
hands boys right [ __ ] can barely get
the sneakers squeaking dude the NBA used
to be the greatest [ __ ] game if you
sat down low to see the game live
there's there's no it's not like hockey
were you behind the [ __ ] glass you
know it's almost like it's soundproof
and even that's still amazing to be down
that close but still there's like this
barrier you [ __ ] sit right down on
the court and they're right there the
[ __ ] ball could bounce into your lap
was insane and and you know look like I
said I'll take 40% of this that this is
just me being a grumpy old man okay you
got to keep the game has to keep
evolving these kids are growing up with
DJ's people are asking them to make
noise and they like to make noise this
is what
[ __ ] generation does fine fine but
can you just dial it back a little bit
every time there was a timeout all of a
sudden there was all these [ __ ]
people running up and by the way the
kids out there they have a kid dance
team can you have him do a [ __ ] kid
dance you know what I mean jesus [ __ ]
christ half those [ __ ] moves I've
seen in a titty bar and I'm a [ __ ]
looking at an eight-year-old did
everybody clap your head the whole
[ __ ] thing was insane and so anyways
and what one of the funny things was I'm
sitting there with Nia right and you
know she's a great person she's not a
grumpy person so she's just enjoying all
of it she's taken it in she's enjoying
the game you know and when all of a
sudden they started like I swear to God
in like little parachutes they drop down
gift certificates to something that
evidently we couldn't afford I don't
know what it was like I tell me what the
[ __ ] it was everybody's jumping up like
leaping up trying to catch these things
like it's you know the end of the
Vietnam War and this is a ticket to get
on the last chopper out of there right
oh no the [ __ ] t-shirts all of this
[ __ ] I hate when they sit there and they
got one t-shirt left and they start
looking at the section whatever section
can make the most noise and just
watching people like a [ __ ] dog
begging for a treat for a free [ __ ]
Clippard a Clippers teach this isn't
even a Lakers t-shirt this is a Clippers
t-shirt just watching all of those
people taking all of their self-esteem
all they have any shred of integrity and
jumping up and down over a [ __ ]
eight-year-old to get a free t-shirt I
don't know so anyways so Nia points out
this some guy sitting in the front row
that she follows on snapchat I believe
it's called I keep calling Instagram
snapchat and he says dude it just goes
yo they don't want you to [ __ ] blah
blah blah blah blah bunnies always doing
whatever they say can't do and she goes
look at him he's down there he's right
there
oh look he's making a snapchat video
she's watching the guide make the
snapchat video then she takes out
cellphone in two seconds later she
watches the thing and I'm watching the
guy down there and doing a snapchat I
just watched the guy fulfillment now I'm
watching on her phone and by the way in
the meantime Steph Curry is going up and
down the flat B body clap your hands
right I got a TD I don't need all of
that [ __ ] so anyways as if that isn't
bad enough as if I haven't been going on
and on you know needing an entire
[ __ ] box of tampons at this point how
much I'm bitching at least I even though
I can't hear it even though there's
gonna be somebody standing up in front
of me even though they're shooting
t-shirts at me and telling me to make
some noise and clap my [ __ ] hands
like I don't know where I'm at okay
Helen Keller should get like this level
of [ __ ] direction if she goes out
she's dead whatever anyways Steph Steph
Curry goes out there immediately gets a
foul I'll give it to you it was a foul
alright three minutes later they call
some ticky-tack horseshit on the guy
he's got two fouls in the first quarter
now they sit him down and old [ __ ]
Freddie stop up and sitting there going
everybody yo-yo stowed yo-yos go back
dog birds laughter I am [ __ ] beside
myself
[ __ ] beside myself going this is why
I [ __ ] hate that this is why this is
why these games get fixed this is why
the NBA is [ __ ] fixed because this is
the only sport of the four major sports
that the goddamn [ __ ] referee can
take the best guy out of the game just
give him two quick ones in the first
quarter can you imagine if you want to
go to a football game right Oh Freddy
StubHub I've gotta see [ __ ] I'm gonna
see Tom Brady versus Peyton Manning the
last time I go to that [ __ ] Broncos
[ __ ] Patriots playoff game and
whatever Tom Brady gets two quick ones
for intentional grounding or some [ __ ]
and next thing you know he's standing on
the sidelines and the [ __ ] backup
quarterbacks in there you're just
standing there like dude are you [ __ ]
serious the guy spent like the whole
first half on the [ __ ] bench it was
brutal and the reps we're calling
[ __ ] everything tea and everybody up
and I actually the only cool part about
sitting down low that I saw was at one
point is it Steve Kerr said his first
name he [ __ ] looks over at Doc Rivers
and they he gives Doc Rivers I like dude
you [ __ ] believe this [ __ ] and Doc
looks back at him like yeah what the
[ __ ]
like sharing this moment just as coaches
like what the [ __ ] of these refs doing
so I don't know what happened at
halftime if somebody called them up and
said hey man this is like one of the
best games of the weekend you [ __ ]
this up all right put your goddamn
whistle away in the second half they let
him play and it was it was beautiful
it's a [ __ ] amazing game despite the
fact all of that [ __ ] was going on I
know I know I went on and on I probably
went on too long I understand but like
you know it's it's such a great game and
you know I kept thinking about me always
watches all like those [ __ ] you know
reality shows and stylist shows and all
that [ __ ]
and you know when they trash people for
what they're wearing if somebody comes
out and be like oh honey - any
accessories you need to take a couple of
things off but just go out like wow you
know if they have like like too many
[ __ ] bracelets and then the [ __ ] I
don't know a hat and a scarf just too
many accessories and they go you just
take a couple of things off before you
go out into the world you know be more
Parisian don't be Tampa Florida okay I
don't know why I said Tampa I just want
to think of no class I just think of
northern Florida yeah I just said that
you offended why don't you look out you
[ __ ] window past the crocodile over
your truck with the steel balls hanging
off the back of it I'm [ __ ] with you
Florida come on man you can't be all bad
if Walt Disney decided to put his world
there
that's what it feel like at those
basketball games they just just dial it
back a little bit okay
could the booty dancers be maybe you
know could they at least be in junior
high cuz could that happen that that
could be nice you know
could you play everybody collapse their
hands maybe just 18 [ __ ] times during
the game you know if somebody pays
through the [ __ ] nose to get sixth
[ __ ] rope could I could I at least
hear the sneakers squeaking they don't
give a [ __ ] you know gives you know what
they should have done at the end of the
game you know like you know that when
you go to the joke shop and you just
open the thing up and all the snakes
would come flying out that's what they
should have done to the whole crowd just
giving him a [ __ ] facial or [ __ ]
t-shirts and you know I got to be honest
with you even from me that was extra
[ __ ]
but once again dude I always stay to the
end of the game I don't know why people
leave and the Warriors were up by like
[ __ ] 12 15 points or something I think
it was no wait they would see they went
by 11 there they look like 15 points and
I think they cut it to 11 and people are
leaving cuz there's only like a minute
and a half left every was like well [ __ ]
this gotta beat the traffic which is
understandable in LA and everybody
starts leaving and I'm psyched because
it's getting quiet and I could finally
hear these guys out on the court right
and so the Clippers bring the ball up
and they this isn't like they've taken
all the stars are out of the game at
this point they just got the bench in
for both teams so what the [ __ ] even
they're saying this game's over Clippers
bring it up they hit a three right so
now it's like a [ __ ] eight point game
warriors whatever they inbound the ball
Clippers steal it run to the three-point
line I'll a [ __ ] Reggie Miller boom
hit another three now it's a five-point
game now the people left like oh [ __ ]
the [ __ ] the worries like okay so dumb
shut it down go to pass half-court they
get it past half court
[ __ ] Clippers steal it again go to
the three-point line boom hit another
one it's a two-point game the people who
are left are going [ __ ] crazy this is
what I wanted now all of a sudden that
[ __ ] putting all the a-listers are
coming back in to save the [ __ ] day
Chris Paul's
back out there [ __ ] Steph Curry the
whole [ __ ] thing the Warriors bring
the ball back up again they somehow lose
the ball three
two the Clipper guys bringing it down he
jumps up in the air looking for somebody
to pass it to and then sees like oh [ __ ]
there's not enough time yet and then
launches an attempt that it looked like
they brought me out on the [ __ ] court
and it felt like that way short it was
just the wrong guy with the ball at the
end of the fight I don't know who the
[ __ ] it was but uh even he looked at me
she just goes like what what was that I
don't [ __ ] know I don't know then
that was the end of the game and then
they were like thanks for coming out
back
but anyways at the end of the day I feel
like I saw Steph Curry I gotta give it
up to the Warriors though man like just
watching the watching them the way they
move with a ball around and all of that
and even with you know their star on the
bench man there was at Thompson I don't
I don't know [ __ ] about hoop as you can
tell Thompson that guy was [ __ ]
killing them and then they got this
other dude they have like backup center
or something this guy is a [ __ ] house
he looks like a defensive lineman if you
know you put six inches on him and he
had one dunk during the game I can't
believe he didn't [ __ ] yank the whole
rim down
it was [ __ ] hilarious he got a head
of steam and everybody just got the [ __ ]
out of the way and if only they weren't
playing Drake during the time when it
happened man I could actually could have
heard that [ __ ] earth-shattering dunk
it was literally 30 feet away I couldn't
even hear it alright I'm done okay I
just had to vent I'm sorry guys I just
you know just had a rough time all right
me [ __ ] I've been talking so much
I've gone into screensaver I can never
remember the [ __ ] password yeah you
know what it is I can't talk and do this
at the same time stupid [ __ ] capital
letters come on one time one time and
then the 52 [ __ ] numbers that come at
the end and of course it's wrong why
would it be right so I literally have to
hit pause
hang on hang in there with me ah when he
gets it all right let's get to let's get
to some of the the advertising here for
this week dude that was literally like a
30 minute [ __ ] [ __ ] fest I literally
should pay for brunch right now thanks
for listening guys I feel so much better
all right blue apron you need to know
how to cook
not only do you feel like you know your
way around a kitchen but cooking at home
means eating healthier and saving money
instead of ordering expensive takeout
again but where do you stat blue apron
as you covered for less than $10 per
meal blue apron delivers all the fresh
ingredients you need to create
home-cooked meals just follow the easy
step-by-step instructions each meal can
be prepared in 40 minutes or less
everybody your hands I do have some
people come up shooting [ __ ]
asparagus at you know overwhelming tips
to the grocery store no more sad takeout
no matter your dietary preferences blue
apron makes it a breeze to discover and
prepare dishes like I can't read that
[ __ ] else else else Asian spice chicken
al SI TI en you know it was that kid
show TI o and Shawn Shawn Shawn Shawn
tion shot cha cha cha is solution cha
cha cha cha cha remember that was at The
Electric Company they were trying to
teach you how to yo and says Shawn sorry
alright I love shad spice chicken with
braised red cabbage smashed potatoes
abused potatoes domestic violence
potatoes no key with shrimp tomato
saffron and olives short rib burgers can
you say heart disease Dodi's got disease
in his [ __ ] right in your own kitchen
cook with yeah this has a bunch of
spelling errors ingredients that you've
never used before like watermelon
radishes and purple potatoes
recipes up between 500
mcalary's proportions calories is felt
run delicious and good for you right now
you can get your first two meals for
free at blue apron dot-com / / that's
blue apron calm / / that's [ __ ] great
they send you everything you learn how
to cook a little bit then that's not a
lot of calories so you stay in shape
watching your figure
alright stamps.com everybody oh [ __ ]
yeah there's only two reads this week
thank Christ
alright stamps calm your to-do lists can
seem a little out of control so much to
do so little time but there's one thing
you can check off your to-do list going
to the post office
thanks to stamps.com with stamps.com you
can buy and print official US postage
not that counterfeit [ __ ] official US
postage right from your own computer and
printer stamps com will send you a
digital scale which automatically
calculates the exact postage you need
for any letter or any package any class
of mail you'll never waste valuable time
going to the post office again you'll do
it in your own house do everything right
now from your own desk with stamps.com
print the postage you need put it on
your letter or package and then just
hand it to your mail carrier I love how
they walk you through the whole process
stick it on the package using your right
or left thumb or possibly your index
finger tuck the envelope under your arm
walk towards your mailbox don't forget
to open the door before you walk through
it and you're done
I use stamps com anytime I'm whoring
myself out selling posters and that type
of [ __ ] you know any time I want to go
out there and deal with every 11th
person having the sweatiest clammy his
[ __ ] hand ever and not having the
decency to give me the fist bump
right now use my last name bur for this
special offer four week trial plus a 110
dollar bonus offer which includes the
digital scale and up to fifty five
dollars free postage do not wait go to
stamps calm before you do anything else
what do I do when I get there click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Barbie URR that
stamps calm
enter BRR ah thank god that's over
thank God it's over I don't like it I
don't like reading out loud I'll admit
it
alright let's continue on here with the
[ __ ] [ __ ] fest is that this podcast
has become this week by the way the
[ __ ] Boston Bruins you know and a
born a game against the Predators lost
two to nothing and then we we went down
three to one against the great Dallas
Stars team one of my favorite [ __ ]
teams to watch that's the team I'm
rooting for out in the West even though
I still love the Blackhawks and the
Kings and I know what you think in
hockey fans how the [ __ ] can you like
the Blackhawks and the kinks they're
rivals
that's because I'm in the Eastern
Conference I don't give a [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ] that you guys hate each
other or I respect both your franchises
alright excuse me for liking what you're
doing in both teams but I like the
Dallas Stars because I don't know I just
I just you know that they're the
upstarts it's always been Kings in
Blackhawks so you got to go for the
underdog right and I don't just like
watching a play so anyways what do I
feel so defensive right now I just enjoy
watching a place so they go up three two
one oh my god it just sucks I'm gonna
swatch my team get their ass kicked but
at least I get to watch I get you I get
to watch this - but that was it and I
bet all you [ __ ] got cowboy fans
watching that hockey I'm getting into
this man whoa that's four goals in one
[ __ ] period called a parry ride yeah
I'm enjoying this man I'm really
enjoying this and then that was it they
got the old right there Fred
right there Fred from [ __ ] the Bruins
little cold lotion few [ __ ] Cowboys
Bruins went on and scored six unanswered
goals Brad Marchand Marsh and however
the [ __ ] he's supposed to pronounce it
they switched it halfway through scored
goal number 29 and 30
I thought he had 29 goals the other day
but he's got he scored 29 and 30 CC's
never scored 30 goals let's go Matt we
haven't had like a big goal scorer in a
long [ __ ] time I'm hoping he scores
50 obviously he's not gonna think he's
gonna make it to that but he could get
40 I'm trying to think the last
who was the last Bruin to score 40 goals
since I've been getting the you know I'm
gonna look that up right now
my only guess that I could make would be
cam neely because there was like a five
year period I barely watched a Bruins
game because I was just
I barely watched any sports because I
was sleeping on a futon and I was
rapidly approaching my mid-30s and I had
to get some [ __ ] going in my career here
all right last Bruin to score 40 goals
you know something it just came up
before I even typed it out this [ __ ]
thing listening to me now he sinks is so
creepy all right who's the last bar just
brewing to score 40 goals in a season
I'm gonna say Cam Neely
that's last one I remember when was the
last time the Bruins won the Cup 2011 we
know that who scored the most don't goes
why the Bruins named the Bruins the
named after a bear I'll [ __ ] you they
don't even necessary but the audio that
they don't even have the [ __ ] general
McGill no the next 40 no list of players
of 50 goals Boston Bruins yeah it's not
even here alright some [ __ ] NHL nerd
if you could [ __ ] answer that one for
me Joe Thornton I don't [ __ ] know
anyways alright let's get on with the
let's get on with the questions here oh
by the way [ __ ] Donald Trump it's
this guy's crushing it he just said that
he feels it's gonna be him and Hillary
Clinton Bernie Sanders doesn't have a
chance and Hillary will make it unless
she gets indicted dude he that guy is so
[ __ ] brilliant he just told everybody
that this is what's gonna happen in the
amount of dopes after watching people
diving over each other for free t-shirts
they're just gonna listen to him and
then that's what's gonna happen and then
he [ __ ] throws a little [ __ ] you
know a little [ __ ] whatever pipe to
the knee of Hillary go unless she gets
indicted which gets that shitstorm going
again
we get invited I have to tell you if
those are gonna be our two choices this
is if it has to be a low point in this
country you don't I mean when we have
the star of a reality show on one side
and then with the filthy [ __ ]
Clintons oh my god and it's not even
Bill Clinton you know I mean it's just
it's just [ __ ] unbelievable it's like
you're literally like I said why would
you hire the plumber's wife to come over
and fix your sink I I don't understand
politics I don't get how you can just
start at such a high [ __ ] level with
no goddamn experience like how do you
just start as a senator you know well
that [ __ ] the mayor in New York
they're Bloomberg I got a billion
dollars yeah I want to run this city now
get those cards out of there I'm gonna
put some chairs down it's like who the
[ __ ] is this guy how come you don't have
to start in the mailroom you know you
hope to start off as like an open-mike
rely CAC immediate well I was married to
a president so now I'd like to be
senator shut up oh god listen to that
[ __ ] voice listen to that voice who
looked at that not a trumpet that
[ __ ] wigwam be a manager shave your
head you know all right to reach for
this week oh no I already got past us
let's get into the let's get into the
questions here for this week let's try
to [ __ ] calm me down you know what's
funny is to listen to this podcast you
wouldn't realize what a [ __ ] great
mood I'm in I'm actually you know I'm in
a great mood this is what I sound like
when I'm in a great mood believe it or
not and I still had a great time at the
[ __ ] game all right just so you know
that okay all right all things comedy
announcement all right this is not
happening
returns to Comedy Central Tuesday night
Friday February 23rd at 12:30 after
midnight this season features long-form
storytelling from all things comics al
Madrigal
christena presence key and Steve Simone
and Felipe Esparza to check that out on
what I say February 23rd I'll that's
tomorrow night
unless you're listening to this in the
future and then you missed it this is
not happening
all right all right now this is
happening I'm reading a question here
all right this guy will you know this
guy had a bunch of [ __ ] so I edited the
whole thing here's this question he says
I'm 35 years old and still living with
my father pathetic I know believe me
it's not by choice
I'm finally recovering from Lyme's
disease which sucked away ten years of
my life and I will have my student loans
paid off in a couple of months what's
also sucked away 10 years of my life
Jesus Christ him coming with the misery
here in a couple of months my father is
selling the house that we currently live
in and moving into a cheaper fixer-upper
so he can be mortgage free I love that
it's a great idea provided you know how
to fix it up speaking of which I got all
the door the last two interior door
locks are gonna work I got a skeleton
key for all of them I'm so ridiculously
excited and for the life of me I can't
find anyone else who gives a [ __ ]
I've had people over the house and I go
look at this isn't this great and
they're like yeah why would you want to
walk doors in your house you know loved
it my mother-in-law she came over and
she freaked she was just like oh my god
she goes that is so cool she totally got
it and that that made it worth it right
there so anyways let me uh let me
continue on he goes so anyways yeah I
paid off his tomb loans he goes out
getting some I hear here's the choice I
have to make I can either live with my
dad even longer than I already have and
be rent free in this fixer-upper so that
I can save up money and get my own place
or I can rent a shitty apartment and
burn a grand a month which would clearly
be better spent on a new house if I was
in my 20s or early 30s I might be a
little more open to the idea of renting
which I did in college the upside of
renting an apartment is having a little
more confidence in integrity when I'm
out on a date knowing that we can
retreat back to my own place instead of
my parents house
well do y-you just hit him with the Lyme
disease [ __ ] story you know and just
telling me I'm living at home because
I'm not dropping a grant I'm gonna be
buying a house and as long as long as
you have a game plan
women will [ __ ] bill they'll ride it
they'll ride it out with you for a
little bit feel like saying listen yeah
I had Lyme disease for ten [ __ ] years
and I finally got over it and I had to
move back in with my dad and that's
brutal right there and moving back in
with my dad you must want to have that
part of a whole nother cellar you know
run-on sentence you just gotta plow
right through that I'd move back home my
dad but I'm on a [ __ ] you gotta sit
you got to say move back home with my
dad but I I almost have enough money for
a down payment on a house so I'm not
throwing $1,000 off Jesus Christ yeah
that's it I'll tell you it's a rough one
you know now you know what [ __ ] these
[ __ ] [ __ ] them [ __ ] them just tell
them what you're doing yeah I'm living
at home because I'm saving up to buy a
house yeah I am 35 just own it yeah
listen I have my own back entrance into
the house my dad won't see anyways this
plow ahead if I was in my 20s or early
30s that might be a little more open to
the idea of renting which I did in
college sorry already read that the
upside of renting an apartment is having
a little more cheese's Christ built all
right it's also the freedom of coming
home to a quiet house and knowing that
my goddamn food will still be in the
refrigerator when I get home my brother
is also still living at home he suffers
from migraines dude what the [ __ ] where
do you what do you live near what sort
of [ __ ] this sounds like one of those
[ __ ] movies where they're you know
they're you guys eating the lead paint
in your house like what's going on here
so now you get Lyme disease what are you
going a [ __ ] hike not wearing any
shoes and get bit by a tick I can't
remember there's too many [ __ ]
diseases anyways he goes so should I get
on with my life and start pissing money
away on rent or should I stick it out a
little longer and continue to live with
with father so I can get my own
fixer-upper love the podcast thanks and
go [ __ ] yourself in the a with addy
kay um alright I would look if you just
have to stick it out a little longer who
gives a [ __ ] at this point you already
did ten years you know if if you can get
yourself in a situation where you can
actually own the place where you're
living when I shouldn't say that you're
basically you instead of having a
landlord the bank's your landlord you
have a mortgage hating people said do
you Rena do I own I own a house we
bought a house oh yeah outright no no
make it mortgage cream all right then
you don't own it somebody owns you right
that's what happened you used to be you
used to you used to be in a situation
where somebody owns you month to month
but any point you could just take off
you could leave the plantation okay now
you just signed up for 30 years but
somebody [ __ ] putting it in you every
[ __ ] month so what I would say is I
would stick it out a little bit longer
with my dad and I would buy a house
where you know it's not one of those
deals where you could just make the
mortgage payment you got to get into a
situation where not only do you making
the mortgage payment but you can throw
something at the principal you know you
got to beat the [ __ ] out of that and you
got to beat the [ __ ] out of it quick
because they front-end load all the
interest which to this day I don't know
why it's legal oh yeah that's right
that's right the president only makes
four in a grand a year that all I think
that's right that's right yeah
and bankers go out and have like
$400,000 [ __ ] you know like I won't
even say Christmas parties I mean that's
what they probably play the outfield to
come and play their daughter's 16th
birthday there's no way they'd pay for
them for Negrin Green Day you could get
Green Day for 400 grand right play a
half-hour in your backyard
that's nothing then what's it that's a
tree oh it's a hundred twenty-five
another thirty three thousand dollars
each hundred thirty-four for the lead
singer because he sees playing all the
guitar parts and singing alright
I'm gonna do a startup I want Green Day
to pay my clay my 48th birthday
all right UK United Kingdom dear bill
when are you coming back to the UK and
are you watching any football
parentheses soccer in between Bruins
games now I've been just I've been
really [ __ ] busy so I haven't gotten
to watch any of that I saw a little bit
the other day I don't know I was in sub
pub I always watch it man
when I can let you know if I get if I
stumble upon it I will watch it but I'm
hoping to do a European tour towards the
end of this summer maybe like in August
be really interesting to go through
Scandinavia you know when the Sun is not
going down at 3:00 and 3:00 in the
afternoon which to be honest with you
actually think is pretty [ __ ] cool
you know I got to admit when I went to
Iceland in December that's the [ __ ]
time to go don't go in the summertime
when every jerk-off is there you go in
the summertime when nobody wants to go
and then you go to that Blue Lagoon
[ __ ] spa it's just that's naturally
heated by the [ __ ] volcanoes i
whatever the [ __ ] it it's it's
incredible it's [ __ ] incredible one
of the one of the coolest places I've
ever been to
but yeah I'm definitely gonna be coming
back doing a big stand-up tour and I'm
gonna be adding some Eastern European
countries and I'm really excited about
that our buddy mine just went to Germany
was saying what a great time they had he
was actually in a bar and met somebody
that knew what my stuff was or something
new someone might stand up jokes or
something so I'm mostly German so I
would be excited to to go back to the to
the motherland there speaking of which I
actually watched this documentary
my wife tape was taught that the
charisma of Adolf Hitler on PBS and it
was this fascinating thing how they
talked about just what is charisma you
know and they had this whole thing we're
saying how like Hitler could not had
just no functioning relationship
with anybody one-on-one but he just
crushed it in front of a crowd and now
he would make him wait and all of that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] hilarious like he's
waiting to start his speech everyone's
cheering and he's just standing there
until they're dead silent you know it
reminded me one time Nia took I took Nia
to go see Erykah Badu and she comes out
and everyone wants to sing and she
spends the first five minutes just
walking around light in the incense so
I'm watching Hitler she got she got this
from Hitler it's the same [ __ ] thing
everybody's I go oh we need to behave
ourselves and then the performance will
begin but they had all these creepy
[ __ ] speeches that he was getting he
was doing this thing where he was going
there's a group of people among us who
can basically live anywhere they do
business anywhere it doesn't matter them
to them they live in Paris next month
they live they'll live in [ __ ] Vienna
then they'll live here and bla bla bla
bla bla with no ties to their homeland
he just keeps spoon-feeding them you
know he won't come out and say it this
group of people because they have no
attachment to Germany you know but bla
bla bla bla and finally something the
crowd goes you yelled out Jews and
Hitler never addressed it and then just
kept going it was I you have to see this
day it is the creepiest absolutely
absolutely creepiest [ __ ] thing I've
ever seen in my life
and then uh but I would I would be lying
to you if I didn't tell you that I
learned some things as far as
performance in front of a crowd I mean
you got to give it up the guy was a
beast
I don't even remotely agree with the
guy's message but Jesus Christ the guys
going out in front of a crowd you know a
Kevin Hart sighs [ __ ] crowd and it
doesn't say a [ __ ] word he doesn't
get to do was the exact opposite of the
Clippers game eggs
right Jesus Christ Hitler's got to come
back and start running the NBA there I
said it I said if he can just get past
the fact that 99% of the players are
african-american I think he could do
some great things for the league I think
he quieted them all right sorry anyways
so I will be going to Eastern Europe
that's what I was trying to say or
Europe in general the UK there we go all
right
Apple fives the FBI dear big brother
Billy what are your thoughts in the
battle between Apple and the FBI
regarding hacking into the the phones of
the San Bernardino terrorists also does
the fact that the FBI has the phones for
two months and can't get into them put a
dent into any government overreach
conspiracy theories no he says the
situation with Apple is FBI wants Apple
to create an operating system that would
allow for them to hack encryption on the
phone they would upload the system to
the terrorists phone to allow them to
unlock it however what they would upload
this system to the terrorists phone to
allow them to unlock it
however if Apple does this the operating
system can be used by the FBI and others
to totally compromise any security on
any iPhone in the future now the
solutions simple it's just like just
bring the phones to us and we'll hack
into it and whatever information need on
the phones will do that for you yeah
once again because of these terrorists
[ __ ] what you're gonna do is that you
can allow all the you know these [ __ ]
lunatics at the top to take even more
power in privacy away from you and I
could just simplest way to tell you this
is just like you know the amount of
people out there can that can actually
handle power is it's very rare I mean
look in my business okay you see what
happens you know everybody's down to
earth everybody's cool and all of a
sudden you get your own sitcom and next
thing you know you're banning people
from the set your tip and [ __ ] over and
nobody's saying [ __ ] because you make it
all this [ __ ] money you don't handle
it well right being
being like in the top levels of
government and security it's the same
[ __ ] thing I don't think they handle
it well I think it's way too much
freedom and I'm sick of people saying
[ __ ] like well hey man if you're not
doing anything then what are you worried
about I'm worried about the fact that
you know just you know well human beings
do we're awful we're [ __ ] terrible
people we're terrible with the amount of
access that we have now you don't need
to give people more access and I don't
feel like you know they keep just hiding
behind this whole [ __ ] thing of like
you know what we're just gonna use it
for the bad people it's like yeah but
you get to decide who the [ __ ] been
that Snowden guy he had to walk away
what they were building was like the
[ __ ] Batman movie they spy on their
own [ __ ] people they're lunatics I
don't know what they do I always
pictured I'm just sitting here [ __ ]
and oh dude you know like that Snowden
guy he says when he stays in a [ __ ]
the hotel room he unplugs the phone
because they had that speakerphone do
you know that down at the front desk
they can turn it on and just listen to
whatever you're doing and they're you
know [ __ ] you lady talking to
yourself rubbing one out whatever the
[ __ ] you doing in the privacy your own
[ __ ] I'll tell them they can just
listen in on that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] it's
just the whole thing is creepy and ya
know it's I can't imagine you know what
by the time you know if I live you know
to be like ninety a hundred years old
like I would like to I want to see the
[ __ ] I want to live in every [ __ ]
decade you know I want to get to the 60s
again I was born in 1968 I want to make
it you know I just keep thinking [ __ ]
like that I want to make it right
so I can't imagine like the lack of
privacy that they'll be if you live that
long just with like people with like
drones and [ __ ] like that like the
cameras and just out like I think in the
future right they're gonna make that I
have like these like microchips like
misters you know and like somebody walks
by and somebody just hits you with a
little mist
and all these little microchips go on
you and when you shower like most of
them come off but like a fuel is still
stick on you and then your next-door
neighbor can just watch your whole
[ __ ] life there'll be no more TV
shows will just be spying on each other
I don't know I think it's all [ __ ]
creepy and I think that's way too much I
don't think the FBI needs to [ __ ] do
that I think Apple should work with the
FBI and if there's ever like somebody
that they want to [ __ ] check in on
you know let them do it Sam call him up
hang on one second cool
all right let's get on to the next one
all right gay friend hey Bill first off
thanks for the lux well you're welcome
I'm 30 years old and decided to go back
to school two years ago to study
chemistry I'm an idiot like you but with
enough effort anything is possible
yep I believe Kevin Garnett said that
during my first semester back I
befriended a gay guy I am not gay myself
nor am i homophobic I've also never had
a gay friend we have a lot in common
except for the fact that he likes to
give and take it up he asked Jesus
Christ dude you could have said except
that he likes gay sex all right
I don't proofread these I just stumbled
on the sentences here we go during that
first semester I started to get the
feeling that he liked me I started to
get uncomfortable studying with them and
stopped answering his phone calls for a
few days after those few days I decided
to call him explain my concerns I told
him that I've never had a gay friend
before I think he's a cool guy but I
also explained that I'm getting the
feeling that he thinks he might have a
chance dude that's you handled it
perfectly he goes he laughed and he
assured me that he wasn't hitting on me
and knew I wasn't gay he also told me
that if he feel he crit if he if I feel
he crosses a line to tell him tell him
okay great I said I don't know dude he
said he wasn't hitting on you and then
he's kind of like yeah if I cross the
line I the way I look at the end of the
day it's a guy alright and guys think
you know if you're talking to him you
want to hook up right that's why women
you know when they walk down the street
guys are like smile say hello it's like
I can't or else you think I want to [ __ ]
you and then I got to deal with that
level of interaction that's why I got to
walk down the street with this Donald
Trump look on my face right the same
thing I always feel I have I feel that
with like gay guys she can't be can't be
can only be so [ __ ] nice or they're
gonna think they got a shot because
they're they were born with the dick
that's what I talk about that you dicks
a dreamer your dick believes man it's
[ __ ] wave and everybody around the
third base all right now I'm in my
second year of school fourth semester
and we have more of the same classes but
not together over the winter break he
called me and asked if I wanted to go to
the bar with him and some other friends
from school I happily said yes and drove
to the bar after about two hours he
asked me if I have any weed and if I'd
smoked smoked him down are we still
talking about weed here what are we
doing
he said I said sure let's go to my truck
and smoke a bowl
during this drunken stoner session he
proceeds to get wet yeah yeah can you
got it so yeah listen dude you know what
your gut was right you called him on the
[ __ ] and he said that he wasn't and I
knew it with that [ __ ] line but if I
ever cross the line let me know dude he
was trying to wear you down he was
trying to hang in there long enough that
you finally just said you know what [ __ ]
it
so basically okay he's getting worried
he goes basically telling you that he
knows I'm not gay but I'm the kind of
guy he likes and I'm one of his best
friends and now his life sucks because
he's gay I just started laughing and
saying what the [ __ ] I'm too nice of a
guy to say get the [ __ ] away from me so
I let him finish his thoughts he was
drunk at being emotional too which was
annoying he reminded me of my
ex-girlfriend I'm just glad he didn't
start crying
anyway after whatever after he was done
I said that's great but I'm not wired
that way
sorry he kept going on and on asked me
if I'm sure there isn't any secret
hidden desired buried deep within me oh
yeah dude it's it's late night it's late
at night this guy he's going all in I
explained to him that if I was doing the
same thing to a girl that I had a crush
on I would be considered a creep and
that the girl wouldn't want to hang out
with me anymore dude why are you writing
me man you got all the yeah handling all
of this perfectly I already failed cuz
the second he got weird in my truck it
would be like get out get out this was
about two months ago and I've ignored
him since he called me three times and I
ignored them
two of the calls were in the middle of
the night no Jesus 1:30 at 2:30 a.m.
which leads me to believe he was being
drunk and emotional exactly he goes just
like a 23 year old girl he goes I don't
see him at school anymore because I
avoid him on purpose my question to you
is am i doing the right thing yes you're
totally doing the right thing it's just
because you'd get both guys and that
because he's gay and he's out like
basically in the media they're always
considered victims if there's any sort
of so like you got to be more accepting
you know at some point if somebody's
making you [ __ ] uncomfortable and you
[ __ ] address it and they still cross
the line if that's something you're not
comfortable with it yeah [ __ ] off it's
over beat it you [ __ ] creeping me out
you know anyways he goes my question to
you is am i doing the right thing I've
never gone out of my way to avoid
someone like this except for a girl
after I break up with them I have no
desire to hang out with them anymore
it's not that big of a deal it's not
like a work friend you hang out with but
then one of you gets a different job and
the two of you stop hanging out I do
feel bad though because he has had a
hard life he's the classic gay guy who
grew up in Texas and was harassed and is
hated by his dad it sucks but it's not
my problem I used to listen to his
problems to try to give him advice on
life and happiness and be a good friend
but after that whole truck and it's
incident I don't want to do that anymore
thanks for the help hope you and the
lovely Nia have a great day yeah now
dude you're [ __ ] you handle it
perfectly you were never a jerk to the
guy you told them exactly
you were feeling at the end of the day
you had respect for yourself in your own
boundaries which he didn't so [ __ ] off
you know yeah teach him a you know teach
him a lesson
next time he has a straight friend you
know just be be a friend don't get high
going to his truck and try to [ __ ] them
yeah it's pretty straightforward
alright germophobe bill though I can't I
don't know leukocyte what the [ __ ] does
that word I got look that word up he
said some [ __ ] spaceship is that a I
don't know what that means I feel like
half the podcast is laughing at me and
the other half is pretend pretending
like they know what the [ __ ] it means
leukocytes
a colorless self that circulates in the
blood and bodily fluids and is involved
in counteracting foreign substances and
diseases and so I'm a white self though
that's that you didn't realize how
[ __ ] original letters I hope I said
the word right Jesus Christ that was
[ __ ] brilliant my hat's off to you
and also ties in with germaphobe
you know whenever you get sick your
white cell count goes up do you realize
on how many [ __ ] levels that insult
is working Jesus Christ tip of the hat
TF all right a few days ago I was
stretching in the gym with the girl I
was dating she picked up her phone from
a bench looked at the screen and said
God my screen is so dirty and then
proceeded to use her tongue to lick the
phone screen and wipe it off with her
sleeve what the [ __ ] she just when you
thought getting high with your gay
friend and he goes for your dick and
your truck was the [ __ ] weirdest
almost uncomfortable thing you were
gonna Jesus he goes I dry heaved and she
got mad at me claiming that she was a
medical student and done things like
that doing things like that was good for
for my immune system [ __ ] med
students always
to tell you they are med students he
goes I couldn't get over it I had to get
away from her now it's in my psyche that
maybe I am a germaphobe when I use an
ATM a debit card PIN pad I always have
to wash my hand touching those things
grosses me out
am ia germaphobe PS how many hands do
you shake a day no dude your girlfriend
is a med student but she's also gross
that's [ __ ] disgusting
period okay there's so many other ways
where you can go into the [ __ ] gym is
enough to keep your immune system up you
don't need to lick your phone you
[ __ ] pig disgusting that's [ __ ]
gross
all right end of story no you're not a
germaphobe you're an intelligent human
being that's an you know you're just
aware yeah I don't like touching those
[ __ ] things when I go to the airport
I got it I got to get on that little
shuttle bus thing and they're like hold
on before the [ __ ] thing starts I
always pull down the sleeve of my jacket
and I hold on to it like that yeah I
don't need fecal matter and mucus and
jizz and God knows what else is [ __ ]
on that thing all right
gross you're not a germaphobe all right
how many hands do I shake a day I don't
know sometimes zero sometimes if I do
wish I don't I don't [ __ ] know I I
know but I go when I wash my hands
afterwards and I don't touch my face
after I do it because I'm afraid I'm
gonna get pinkeye but I don't shake a
lot of hands but I will say people love
coming out of the bathroom and then be
like hey Belle I'm then shaking you anti
I really got it in the moment get better
be like dude know what you just came out
come on give me the elbow dude you just
came out of the bathroom I don't know
you I don't know if you're good at
washing your hands I want to know you
like that all right dilemma hey Bill oh
that reminds me a long time ago I worked
the improv in Dallas and I pissed off
this [ __ ] oh I think I pissed off
this older Texan guy or maybe this was
this weird idea of humor he came up and
shook my hand right at the end of the
show I say hey man thanks for coming out
and he just goes I
just paid that was like I you know I'm
not gonna do anything with my hand my
hand is that you could have your urine
on it it's fine I'm not gonna eat I'm
just gonna shake a bunch of other hands
now they're gonna have you pee on it
and then I'm gonna wash you my hands
it's gonna be over you don't I mean you
don't think you got you just went into
the bathroom you know have any idea
what's on your [ __ ] hands that's now
on my hands yeah we're all filthy
alright dilemma hey Bill so I'm in a bit
of a tight situation me and some buddies
were planning to take on taking a
weekend trip down to Austin to attend a
music festival my lady's grandma is
getting married the same week the same
weekend as the concert obviously I have
to pick my ladies grandma is getting
married the same weekend as the concert
obviously I have to pick which event I'm
going to attend your girlfriend's
grandma is getting married
well when the [ __ ] did grandma have her
mother when she was like 12 my girl
there's no choice here this isn't a
dilemma this is like an obvious because
my girl left it completely up to me with
no hard feelings attached at least from
her I'm afraid of upsetting her family
by not going to the wedding
[ __ ] that go to the [ __ ] wedding look
if you got to marry this girl you have
to establish early that you're not going
to every stupid [ __ ] function you
have to do that he goes but I should
mention that my my girls grandma doesn't
really care much for me or so it seems
she tells my girlfriend that she should
explore her options a bit while she's
still young also and I also have not
been formally / officially invited my
girlfriend and I have been dating for
two years so it's not like I'm a new
boyfriend or anything what should I do
I'd love to hear the lovely Nia's take
as well if she's around unfortunately
she's not around they would [ __ ] that
you go down with your friends and you go
to the concert you have a great [ __ ]
time okay and if this woman doesn't like
you at the end of the day she's gonna
die soon so who gives a [ __ ]
okay it gives us [ __ ] it's not like her
mom doesn't like it then that's a
problem because she's gonna be around
and he gonna have kids and she's gonna
[ __ ] show up and it's gonna be a big
[ __ ] pain in the ass grandma gives a
[ __ ] right should explore her options is
she still running around single in her
[ __ ] 80s you know she's just
projecting her own regret of that
[ __ ] oxen driver she married back in
the 1920s whatever the [ __ ] she did yeah
go to the concert it's not a dilemma
dude go to the concert
just tell your girlfriend so you know
what I decide I'm gonna go to the
concert have a good time with the
wedding and just [ __ ] leave it at
that
and if she gives you a rough time about
it don't bring up the fact that your
grant or grandma doesn't like you and
blah blah blah because then she's gonna
try and fix it no you guys just need to
spend more time together just tell her I
would just I would rather go to the
concert yes I just leave it at that if
she gives you a ton of [ __ ] just be like
listen you know if I invited you to some
but you you know also had plans to go to
a concert you chose to do that I
wouldn't give you a rough time about it
I would want you to do what was gonna
make you happy I would appreciate if you
extend me the same courtesy yeah I see
now I I was gonna say your [ __ ] self
so and so don't don't do the last part
alright that's what I would do
alright okay there you go alright that's
the podcast for this week everybody
everybody yo heads thank you for
listening and thank you to everybody
that's uh you know coming out to the
shows this weekend at Foxwoods
you know I some people were talking
about you know the ticket prices and
everything I can't control that people
go on and buy some he's [ __ ] scalping
ticket things you know the StubHub
peoples of the [ __ ] world so I got to
figure something out with that i know
louis c.k does something where he sells
tickets you know on his own website but
my thing is like well then how do you
stop them from just going to your
website and buying up a bunch of tickets
and sending the [ __ ] price through
the roof like how do you do it because I
don't want you guys getting [ __ ] over
but I can't tell you this if you do go
and you do pay through the nose there
won't be anybody screaming and yelling
and shooting [ __ ] t-shirts at you
while I'm doing my dick and [ __ ] jokes
alright okay
that's the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
and I'll check in on Thursday